à l'est de la méditerranée dans cette
région du monde que les français
appellent le proche orient entre les
neiges de l'anti liban et la mer rouge
deux ou trois désert et un troupeau de
collines inégalement fertile forment les
trois domaines de cana en la terre
promise
la palestine enfin depuis des
millénaires carrefour rarement
silencieux des ambitions des convoitises
des religions et désespérance humaine
après la première guerre mondiale un
royaume sous dynastie hachémite et
mandat britannique s'est formé là de
quelques dépouille sablonneuse tombé du
colosse hautement la jordanie monarchie
constitutionnelle et parlementaire qui
jusqu'à la guerre de six jours
réunissait sous son autorité
hospitalière et indolente la plus grande
partie de la terre sainte et de ces
hauts lieux
à l'exception de la galilée oedème karim
village la visitation
c'est sur cette terre aujourd'hui
passablement déshérités que campe les
trois grandes religions monothéistes de
l'univers le judaïsme christianisme
islam
toutes trois points géographiques et
spirituel culminant jérusalem et une
seule a commencé il y a deux mille ans
dans le décor de bethléem dont la
douceur étonne au creux des arbres
montagne de judée à 9 kilomètres de
jérusalem alors que la succession des
collines crayeuse semble annoncer le
désert le voyageur découvre tout à coup
derrière un vallonnements rap est un
tableau de franges hélico en grandeur
nature elle peint avec la même
délicatesse et la même fraîcheur
c'est ici chacun c'est cela que le
christianisme est né
l'église de la nativité est un édifice
médiéval carré compact où l'on entre par
une porte basse d'un mètre de haut à
peine qui comptera le pèlerin à courber
le dos et inauguré sa visite par un acte
d'humilité de ce lieu obscur est sortie
la plus grande tempête spirituelle qui
soit jamais passé sur le monde et elle
n'a pas fini de souffler
le jourdain est un fleuve de 320 km qui
traverse lac de tibériade pour aller se
jeter dans la mer morte après un
parcours légèrement si lieu vers la fin
duquel se situe le lieu dit du baptême
du christ c'est ici que saint jean
baptiste vite arriver un jour lettre
qu'ils avaient copieusement annoncé dans
le désert et dont il se disait indigne
de délier la sandale
et cette petite colline tranché en deux
comme un pâté et l'antique jericho qui
raconte neuf mille ans d'histoire sous
la forme d'une superposition de ruines
précises comme un calendrier à quelque
distance de la ville au dessus des
palmiers et des orangers de la plaine
s'élève le monde la tentation où l'on
sait que le christ fut tenté par satan
après 40 jours de jeûne et de prières
des moines n'ont pas résisté à la
tentation de bâtir un couvent au sommet
de la montagne du haut de laquelle le
mirage des royaumes terrestre fut
proposée aux fondateurs du christianisme
mais voici jérusalem l'inoubliable
l'antique jérusalem prises dans la
couronne d'or de son mur dentelée
semblable aux villes sans perspective
des vieux livres d'heures à ma
désordonnée de coupoles et de lens où
l'on discerne d'autres espaces libres
que l'esplanade du tank
c'est ici que la religion chrétienne
menées avec les aime aurait pu mourir et
de mourut pas
et après l'image des oliviers de
gethsémani commence le chemin de la
croix qui par les ruelles étroites les
voûtes les escaliers de la vieille ville
à travers les éclats de soleil et
l'odeur des souks mène au golgotha
enchâssée dans une basilique maintes
fois détruite et reconstruite au dessus
du rock ensanglanté de la passion et
aujourd'hui préservée à grand peine de
l'effondrement par une sorte de corset
de tubulures d'acier en ce lieu mourut
jésus-christ déposée non loin de là dans
le tombeau que les saintes femmes
toujours seul à l'avant garde de la
passion si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
trouvèrent vide le matin du troisième
jour une coupole noir et une coupole
blanche symbole de la mort et de la
résurrection surmonte cet édifice où le
rocher encastré de marbre précieux ne se
voit plus que par une petite ouverture
circulaire ménagers dans une dalle
précautions prises pour empêcher
certains pèlerins entreprenant de raser
peu à peu le rocher ou qui sait de
graver leurs initiales en ce lieu se
rencontrèrent un jour toutes les
souffrances de la terre et tout la pitié
des cieux
de là nous revenons vers le centre de la
ville imaginez mais vous allez l'avoir
une vaste plage sur laquelle en se
retirant la mère aurait déposé un
splendide coquillages bleus c'est
l'aspect actuel de l'esplanade du temple
lieu géométrique des adorations juive
chrétienne et islamique au centre enclos
dans les manifs hissant orientale de la
mosquée d'omar lapointe émergentes du
mont moriah table des sacrifices de la
religion juive et point d'appui de son
alliance divine les trois grandes
religions sont groupés ici le rock
représente israël le coquillage bleus
l'islam est tout autour les parvis où
jésus a enseigné
j'ai 2 1 à mohammad rasoulof
madame alençon
non
grâce à laon
on ira notamment
il y aura le ballon
à soleure
hamon
hop
en descendant de jérusalem vers le
jourdain on aperçoit quelques distances
de la mer morte
les bretons furent découverts récemment
le célèbre manuscrit sur lesquels de
savants auteurs ont édifié tout une
religion d'attentes entre l'ancien et le
nouveau testament déroulées ces
inestimables manuscrit sans les détruire
a été un véritable exploit
ils auront été plus facile à lire qu'à
ouvrir et il reste plus facile à lire
qu'à comprendre
non
et voici au terme de notre voyage
scintillante au fond d'une gigantesque
failles de l'écorcé terrestre
les surfaces presque inerte et bleu de
la mer morte immense bac luisant enfoncé
et 400 mètres au dessous du niveau des
mers et d'où s'élèvent tout le jour sous
un ciel de plomb dell chimiques vapeur à
sa gauche quand on vient de jéricho le
sommet rectiligne des mondes mahb où
moïse au terme de ces quarante années de
cheminement à travers les sables
d'egypte aperçu les blancs colline de la
terre promise au fond le souvenir
vaporeux de sodome et gomorrhe disparu
dans un nuage de soufre dont ils
semblent flotter encore quelque chose au
dessus des eaux
à droite les vestiges du kir bête qumran
et les grottes bibliothèque dont nous
parlions il ya un as tu es dans ce décor
impressionnant avant que ne tombe la
soie fine des nuits palestinienne des
jeunes femmes toutes pareilles à ce
qu'elles furent de tout temps danse le
sa main et leur pas léger traces sur la
poussière la parabole du temps qu'ils
croient fuir en tournant lentement
autour de l'éternité
e